it's wild that one door closes and then
something else opens and opportunities
appear dancing with the who it's been
good to be back working I'm so excited
for the things that are possibilities
right now dance pros artemchik VIN Civ
and Sharna Burgess didn't make the cast
of Dancing with the Stars new season but
that hasn't slowed them down one bit the
universe works in really wonderful
mysterious and magical ways and you just
have to trust it turns out Chara and
Artem are teaming up to work on another
hit dancing show So You Think You Can
Dance I'm about to head to my second or
her sofa so you think he and dance
because yes I'm car driving this way but
guess what it's not just me I am car
driving with Adam we have teamed up and
we are doing a routine for us oh you
think I can't tell you what it is can't
tell you who it's with but I can tell
you that it's a lot of fun and that you
definitely shouldn't miss out on it
Sharna announced the news on her
Instagram stories Tuesday after having
lunch with the Dancing with the Stars
host Tom Bergeron I got to meet up with
Tom and hang out and catch up on all the
things it feels like it's been so long
since I've seen him and it's just so
beautiful to always catch up with family
and I got so much love for that man ét
recently caught up with Artem who opened
up about the ABC shows decision to cut
him in Sharna from this season's list of
pros added that he was shocked that
Sharna wasn't asked back after winning
last year's mirror ball trophy and he
admitted that Sharna was even more
shocked than he was by the decision
before sharing the big So You Think You
Can Dance News Sharna posted this sweet
photo of her and Tom alongside the
caption quote had a hot lunch date today
always family loved seeing your face Tom
you are an awesome human Tom's co-host
Erin Andrews showed some love in the
comments posting a bunch of heart emojis
you
[Music]